Do you attribute that to exhaustion or do you attribute that to a lack of
recovery from the previous night's workout?
Is it a combination of those things?
Is it exhaustion causing you to miss step perhaps and like twist an ankle or
turn a knee?
Yeah,
it's all of those things.
All those things.
I mean,
even if you look at micro balance,
if you look at sort of the stability muscles versus you know,
major muscles,
those stability muscles also fail when you're not getting sufficient sleep.
And I think we often underestimate how critical they are in sport performance,
particularly in terms of combating and placating injury risk to see if you just
get someone on a stability ball,
you know,
um,
sort of just dose them down with sleep eight hours,
five hours,
you know,
three hours.
And just notice how those stability muscles help you balance just the basic act
of balance that deteriorates dramatically.
No wonder you're getting more injury risk.
Totally makes sense.
Now,
as a neuroscientist,
what do you attribute when,
when,
when people talk about visualization and visualization is a,
uh,
it's a huge factor in improving technical skills.
Uh,
specifically martial arts,
which is a big fan of obviously martial arts.
When you,
you visualize people who visualize,
who sit down and like go over their body,
going through the motions and doing things there,
those people perform better,
they perform better,
they um,
they,
they learn quicker.
What do you attribute that to?
Do you think it's the same thing as what's happening when you're sleeping?
Just maybe to a lesser extent.
I think it's to a lesser extent,
but people have done those studies where they've looked at sort of whether you
actually physically practice let's say on a keyboard,
just cause it's easier to sort of manage in Illawarra tree versus just imagining
sort of typing out that sequence and just the act of physical visualization,
of sort of imagination of that motor skill.
It's,
it's about 50% as effective as physically performing it too.
And it's 50% as effective.
What I mean there is in changing the plastic connections within the brain.
So even just visualization,
passive play as it were still can actually cause a rewiring of the brain
beneficially.
Wow.
You know,
learning techniques,
specifically martial arts techniques.
Um,
my good friend Eddie Bravo,
so world famous Jujitsu instructor,
he's,
he's always um,
comparing it to tying your shoe.
And he said,
do you know how like when you were a little kid and you're trying to figure out
how to tie your shoe,
it's an extremely difficult thing to do.
You're like,
how do I do this?
And you put that down and do loops.
Like I'm watching my seven year old daughter go through that right now.
But now as a grown man,
when I tie my shoe,
I could just be talking,
you know what?
Oh yeah,
we're going to go tomorrow and I'll do it.
I don't,
I don't even know what I did.
If you tried to ask me to how I tie my shoe,
I'd be like,
how do I tell my shirt?
Like I don't even know how I do it because it just,
I have it in there.
It just,
it.
And the idea with martial arts is you've got to be eat.
All of your techniques have to be automatic.
Someone extends the arm,
you instantly hook it and go into the arm bar.
You know,
someone,
you,
you have to have these paths like so drilled in that you don't even know you're
doing them until it's over.
Yeah.
So automaticity is one of the things that sleep actually accomplishes.
I was talking about those 20 to 30% benefits in motor score performance.
So we did some additional studies to actually say,
well what,
how it,
how does sleep do that?
You know,
where in your skill performance to sleep give you the benefit.
So you're right.
Tying a shoe lace,
um,
you know,
even driving a car with a stick,
at first it's just overwhelming.
It's so difficult to clutch it's gas pedal,
you know,
it's gear and now it's just second nature.
You know,
it's shifted from conscious to automatic,
from conscious and unconscious.
If you look at performance that is conscious and not automatic,
it's usually very staccato.
It's this,
then it's that,
then it's that it's not fluid.
If you had someone trying to sort of play piano to begin with,
doesn't sound very fluid.
You know,
someone who is a maestro,
it just flows out of them.
So we looked at this with motor skill performance.
Again,
sort of like keyboard playing musicianship and you learn and you learn,
you get better.
And let's see that you type a sequence that take four one,
three,
two,
four and people learn it,
but they have these problem points throughout the sequence.
They go four one,
three,
two,
four,
one,
three,
two,
four as if it's,
there's a sticking point.
It's the same thing with any skilled performance in,
in athletics.
And it's the brain chunking things up.
A very long motor sequence gets chunked up into small sort of digestible bites.
It's a good way to begin learning,
but it's not a way to create automaticity.
At some point.
What you have to do is stitch all of those things together and it just flows
like a sentence.
Like a sentence.
Yeah,
like a piano piece,
like a,
you know,
a sequence of movements.
If you've got,
you know,
in martial arts you've got,
so what we found was that before sleep,
you've got these big problem points,
these gaps in your motor skill.
Learning.
Sleep does not necessarily improve the places where you're already good.
Sleep is intelligent.
It goes in fines,
that problem point,
that friction point in your motor skill sort of deficit,
and it smooths it out.
So you come back the next day and now it's just four,
one,
three,
two,
four,
three,
two,
four,
three.
It's automaticity and it's exactly what you're describing,
you know,
speak to musicians.
They'll say playing.
I just couldn't get that piece the night before.
And then it came back the next day and I sat down and I could just play.